that's really the question is who is
gonna break you know and it's I think
the pressure is getting to all of us and
that one you know it at some moment in
the season it looks like any one of us
could sort of snap while the first
season of bloodline was a slow burn of
greatness the cat says season two moves
fast this is not steroids is this who's
like they coming for you run I think
what we shot is more of a conflict
between the members after after the fact
of the matter so we had a lot of fun it
was I think it's gonna be really good
from what the reviews say it's a quick
paced fast moving this is gonna really
move fast
and we have some new characters coming
into the mix Beau Bridges joined the
cast well you're in bloodline pretty
convoluted okay you know I guess let me
put it this way to begin with I'm a
mentor for Kyle Chandler share everyone
thinks Beau Bridges is this great sweet
lovely innocent man he's an even the
shower in real life real life he is in
the show is it evil evil evil evil man
season two of bloodline is streaming on
Netflix now how many ways to meet those
people that you're gonna be in for a
really dark evening you better you
better be prepared cuz it's gonna rock
your world cuz it's really edgy creepy
stop sometimes all there is
there's more darkness